or between this in Israel just to give a
general explanation in Israel we have
according to the law we have to give
everything that you write about military
and intelligence issues to the military
censorship this book was submitted to
military censorship when it came back I
counted 750 deletions and a tedious
negotiation started with them and we won
and we with submitted some appeals to
supreme cause we won in most cases one
of them is the case of Nachum man bar an
Israeli businessman ex officer with the
IDF a hero of the Yom Kippur October 72
the war who became a businessman and
cynically cruelly and viciously sold
chemical warfare to Iran the fact that
this was not caught by Mossad in time
and the whole affair were banned by
military censorship I appealed to
Supreme Court in one and there's a
chapter in the book called the termites
file because the whole operation was
codenamed the termite describing the
operation in some cases we reach
compromise one of them was very funny I
think there was there's a there's a
chapter called the second coming of
Hezbollah that starts with an interview
with a Mossad prominent figure dealing
with Hezbollah in which it says in 50
years when they opened the secret files
people in Israel would be amazed to how
poor was the human penetration of
Israeli intelligence into Hezbollah
Wendy when people would read these
secret files that would be shocked and
sad to see that Mossad looked far less
like James Bond and far more like
Inspector Clouseau and then he asked me
do you know how many real agent did
Israel have in the ranks of Hezbollah
like in the true ranks not in the
sympathizers not in outside circles
Hizballah troops and he lived some
fingers of his right arm now military
censorship took everything out we
appealed against it and the outcome was
a compromise
in which they permitted to publish
everything and it's in the book except
for the exact number of fingers that he
lifted so if you read it you see that
it's somewhere between 1 and 5 because
it's only his right arm and no fingers
were chopped in previous operations but
there's no exact number now I think it's
ridiculous but yet we had to reach some
sort of of compromise I would say this
the bottom line is 95% of this book is
new information and I think that after
all the knowledge of the reader of
what's going on in that clandestine war
between Israel and the United States on
one hand in Iran on the other was not
severely damaged by this censorship